[Applaudissements]
les cougars rugissent de plaisir
lézignan montant remporté ce dimanche 14
mai une victoire au forceps dans les
derniers instants contre
saint-just-saint-rambert 10 à 9
un résultat qui s'ajoutent à une
démonstration dans la matinée de
l'équipe 9 à 4 face aux auvergnats
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai senti
une petite baisse deuxième match il a
fallu remettre toutes les toute la
troupe en route
et puis il a fallu le déclin petit
déclencheur une frappe qui emmène une
autre frappe de l'autre côté on a une
équipe qui a commencé à faiblir à la
septième manche 8e manche et on a pris
le dessus de victoire importante dans la
course aux premières places lésigny
montants sont pour le moment quatrième
du championnat sur huit équipes engagées
on va rester serein on va garder la tête
froide aient encore beaucoup de matches
la saison ne fait que commencer et on va
on va prendre les matches un par un et
on garde le même objectif c'est rester
en milieu de tableau pour réaliser cet
objectif montigny le bretonneux a
effectué un recrutement en adéquation
avec ses ambitions
ces derniers jours deux japonais ont
rejoint l'effectif liautaud et schori
sur le terrain aussi ils sont là ils
font leur job enfin on sent que c'est
des gars qui ont une expérience et qui
nous amène ça et c'est vraiment
important pour l'équipe mon premier but
cette année est de gagner le championnat
de france
personnellement j'aimerais faire une
bonne saison pour jouer aux états unis
et deux japonais sur une nouvelle fois
sur la feuille de match pour le
déplacement de montigny le bretonneux à
clermont ferrand le dimanche 21 mai une
équipe que les cougars ont dévoré au
match aller